citizens of the reject Nation we are
coming at you today with Batman the long
Halloween part one neither of us have
seen it as is tradition true have read
it have you read it I have read it it's
been a while in fact I think this would
have been an opening day of the Dark
Knight waiting 12 plus hours in line
with the paperback it is a damn fine
novel I'm very excited to dive into the
animated to see how it adapts itself
please do like comment subscribe hit
that notification Bell so you can see
when part two pops up as well as the
rest of our dcau journey speaking of
Batman
the Batman shirt is available from shop
zero edition.com and we are also going
to be at Comic-Con and if we see you
wearing this shirt we're gonna give you
a nice crisp high five gonna be very
Adam Westy because it's gonna be more
loving than violent but we can promise
you some dancing uh we're gonna be there
on Saturday early afternoon we got tons
of details to come very very soon by the
time you see this video but know that if
you're there Saturday early afternoon
the real rejects will also be there
Marvel ran away from us so you got time
you're not gonna be standing in the hall
h line you're gonna be standing in our
line so we'll see you there at Comic-Con
you lovelies and speaking of excellent
Vigilantes I would like to thank all of
the patrons for joining us as ever if
you want to watch this front to back
start to finish we want some resting
faces
then you become a patron and you can be
super sexy like the rest of them as we
watch this in its entirety without
further Ado let's get Halloween
animatic very uh Batman series there we
go there's the ticket maybe it was just
a silent intro it's just luring you in
with it deeper oh that's gorgeous look
at that establishing wow that may be my
favorite establishing shot today that
was stunning Gotham City
[Music]
I only came here out of respect from my
parents who knew your family that is
definitely a Jensen Ackles Thomas Wayne
believed in my father he believed a man
could bring order to a world of chaos he
also celebrated Halloween and you Bruce
every year they're doing a good job of
the Jeff Loeb writing but also the Tim
sale art but not as directly as the
Frank Miller it's like shades of it yeah
Tim sale passed away last year and uh
one of the most formative Batman artists
one of those forms of comic artists of
all time rest in peace what uh what a
Titan whoa
thank you
scallops though
oh there it is already I can just feel
like the pace the tone feels different
seems like this will have a lot more
breathing room I love the art style the
watercolor blend oh there's my Tim
sailor oh yeah
well this is taking me back this book
has beautiful art it really does
oh rest in peace
and like we saw the Frank Miller that
was like a direct adaptation this is
more like shades of because I don't know
if the Tim sale style would translate to
movement as linear because like this
just so striking in its pauses yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like it's made to be
still see yeah a little bit because I
remember the like Splash pages in this
where you like Turn the Page and you
just stop
[Music]
whoa
come a long way from Red Hood boy this
is incredible I love this music too
you're the only person who probably
feels a little cooler than Batman right
the only person that could even
comprehend what it's like to feel as
cool as Batman that was sick love it
love it love it
oh that's right
nicely done how about the nipple
silencer I miss Kyle telephone she said
she was checking the number you gave her
to make sure it's real
it's an absurd holiday oh yes putting on
costumes and striking fear quite absurd
and collecting candy do you really think
that's how it feels Bruce
yeah Bruce just stole Alfred's bit
I mean many of them is am I six training
excited Jim
cop ghost the specter
Easter egg
when I'm on my way your father's captain
now the whole Department's counting on
him well I was counting on him too
oh Gilda there you are Harvey you home
better late than never the most built
D.A do you have any kids
trick-or-treaters I don't think I'm
really up for all that tonight yeah I
saw the ball on the porch it's okay it's
a ghost town out there there were a lot
of kids out from just now
he's helping her feel better but uh it's
awesome I'm dedicated to Halloween over
anyone's feelings sit on that porch
you have to go pick a movie I'll be back
soon I love you
oh I love that it actually feels like a
Halloween movie like there's a spooky
ethereal like kind of yeah pervades the
whole sort of ambiance yeah it feels
like I like want to watch this on
Halloween with lights off yeah maybe
it'll be part of the new uh every annual
rotation yeah gentlemen
return you Harvey bats dead
okay
Johnny Beatty was murdered tonight it's
Carmine Falcone not the right calm down
where were your men Jim oh
hard to tell if we're dealing with a
professional of course it was a
professional this was Falcone he found
out video
so he took him
up praised the art in the photos
he was ready to sing not just about
Carmine the whole family was going away
we had a real opportunity to change
things a complete Opera
it
who did Salvatore moroney if anyone is
responsible for my nephew's death it's
that new son of a [__] in the DA's
office
Sling Blade over here yep just say the
word come on and I'll do that myself at
the right time we'll hit back and the
right time is now Carmine no disrespect
come on
ooh too late it's Godfather he looks
like Don corleo you see how we've drawn
him
I mean that was a lot of difference
oh buddy
oh damn
thank you
as the elements and the sound design the
watercolored like background yeah
wait do you see what's inside oh this
was a work thing that we were flirting
the only thing that doesn't work with
Jensen Ackles is Batman is both of his
voices sound too cool you'd recognize
him that's true he doesn't have the
perfect gravels it's authentic so Chris
I
actually it's incredibly dirty falcony's
been having trouble laundering his cash
for some time
oh damn let him go because he's with me
also because he's the D.A who put all
your friends into Arkham we got room for
one more yeah of course you do Falcone
owns the mayor and the entire city
assembly so the only way to make an
impact is to make it disappear moving it
could take days burn it well who said
anything about moving it
why are you trying to hurt Falcone well
why are you it's not personal sweetheart
it's Justice
it can be personal assistant yes
heads we burn it down okay
[Music]
oh the cut oh no oh fantastic
Batman shops at magic stores
oh man
got a huge break tonight on this Falcone
Thing Once I take him out we can start a
family you know I can't we'll talk about
options when you're ready but no are we
still having movie night or not yeah
what'd you pick
take off your Mia Wallace costume
oh no oh I knew and I was still shocked
I completely forgot
damn paste it just well enough that I
was like oh look how cute
[Applause]
great Batmobile
Taki is roasting the pies are cooling
and Kyle is on
make a note to order a new windshield
bulletproof it wasn't bulletproof to
begin with I don't know how that went
over the hell you think this is come on
this is Gotham
oh this is Chinatown yeah
ever seen that have you ever seen
Chinatown that like Jack uh I've tried
Nicholson movie I've tried to watch it a
few times okay I quote it but I've never
seen it yeah this is Chinatown I don't
know what that means yet you will
someday someday oh dope shot
Batman movies need more chinatowns
oh
you thought wrong
ah we buddies were seen outside Harvey
Dent's house on Halloween we were
trick-or-treating
show me your candy having fun not yet
but any second now no
no damn
yeah Big Trouble in Little Chinatown
damn
[Laughter]
nicely done
like the martial arts in this yeah
damn
don't tase me bro
Beast of a dude
hey was it good
keep an eye on your little friends
a thank you would be nice
thank you
we can make this easy Mickey just tell
me who hired them to kill Dent go the
hell
the only difference between you and me
is that I know what's down here
there's a Killer Croc looking in these
sewers straight line
dough there he is
Grundy my man there he is
born on a Monday this is your place give
them to me and I'll make sure he never
sets a book down here again
take him good I got my Cameo for the day
there it is you guy
yes
where were you on Halloween you're late
it's fine it's good he's thankful he's
more of a holiday man he gets into the
season oh this one's done for your
husband it's for you from um Mr Falcone
I'm sorry ma'am it's none of my business
isn't it time for his dinner it's not my
business what the hell are you doing
tied up with gangsters also how does she
not a scratch on her she was in that
fire I know I just holding a man
I don't even know come on Falcone the
Roman contracted your Triad to take out
Harvey Dent your signatures all over it
you gotta help me keep my friend here
calm
good cop bad cop Batman good cop bad cop
Jazz are for suspects this guy's
Anderson oh geez
I want to do that to somebody that's
great we have a lot to be thankful for
Alberto Health family what's left of it
if you are referring to your cousin
Johnny that is being handled by Mickey
Chen and who do you think hired him
I love the sound effects
this is such a good job gaffing this is
there something you wish to say except
to point out that Harvey Dent is still
alive is that Jack Quaid
because I allow it
the dangers of independent thought
sounds like Jack yeah that sounds like
Titus Welliver when have you had one
independent thought maybe when I sent
flowers to dense hospital room in the
Falcone name you did what
Oh I thought it would take suspicion off
of us if we look like we care about his
recovery now I suppose you'll say it was
a sloppy move why did you send them in
that name
two for two excellent work
any notion you may hold about being next
in line to take over our business
interests is a pathetic delusion yeah
[Music]
I'm on my way home for Thanksgiving
dinner you should come along Barbara
always makes a ton I'm not hungry
flip a coin
what are we doing here maybe I wasn't
ready for this yet I think I'm gonna go
back now don't you worry about Harvey
um already worried
when a guy acts like that you hand him a
gun yeah the falconies are dangerous
people and to them you're the bad guy
protect your family protect your girl
who's clearly been off this whole time
[Laughter]
[Music]
that nip
oh Batman
giving Grundy some turkey a little
Thanksgiving for Solomon
thank you
shocks Batman
Gordon laughed
foreign
[Music]
work on that one close up
meanwhile at the top of Mount Crumpet
the Grinch continued plotting his heart
would not grow three sizes that day I
should be out hunting we've got it
covered all of Gotham PD will be
deployed throughout town by midnight oh
and when he said hunting he meant like
on Supernatural when holiday comes
calling touch we'll be ready you know
this is all you I wanted them and Gotham
Penitentiary oh my God that is a
different looking Jonathan
Charlie Day oh but this court thing on
Hard Times
mapping things in
calendar man who killed Johnny VD on
Halloween vidi was the Roman's nephew
the Roman was Chen's employer first
suspect is therefore the Roman
I told you to bring Mr Dent he isn't
safe out there the TA who put you all in
Arkham half the patients here would kill
him on site so I'd say out there is the
only place he is safe
six of one half a dozen of the other or
perhaps he doesn't know you're here
perhaps
the district attorney is a suspect
um
love his voice there's lots of crazy out
there these days and just when you
thought you'd cleaned it all up oh what
a joke oh no why did you make that
reference
no it's too easy
too easy
unknown yes
whoa
[Laughter]
he had somebody get to my kid if I
didn't help him I'm sorry oh buddy
outside it suits awful chiller
[Laughter]
good rendition
oh there's that art
looking for this
Put the gun down and we'll talk
oh geez just shot a point blank in the
nuts almost
bullets or keep count oh
wow
where did you get that why
you missing one
D.A Dent is more than he appears to be
I'll make sure little Gilda doesn't have
to close shop a hubby wubby ever again
you call that a joke but you but you
haven't even heard the punchline it goes
like this
ah it's not your best material Joker it
worked for me I'll take a good punchline
all right any idea where he was heading
Moroni Manja
no that's snowpack
[Music]
what happened to your friend's face
Maroney nothing what happened to yours
[Music]
he was inside before we got there took
out the whole staff poisoned the fajol I
wasn't hungry but uh Freddy here not the
forzole he put a gun in my face and told
me that this is his Turf and that he's
cracking down on interlopes freaks used
to play Way Out On The Fringe but once
you showed up yeah relax pal yeah now we
got killer Crocs and moths and Sewer
zombies yeah a homicidal maniac
sculpting around the holidays it made
men
what's the common thread where is he but
if he's the guy killing Falcone's men
it's only a matter of time till he gets
to Old Carmine himself maybe start there
yeah just Shadow Carmine the whole night
easy
sleep with two eyes
oh what my pet gun
hello
what the hat if you're gonna kill me
just do it
do it face of a killer
if you hear any news about the holiday
investigation I'd like you to pass it my
way
heart
[Laughter]
the hell
looks like a good time
boys
[Music]
kiss him it's the rules
no
dang Jesus hand Cannon God that is like
a giant gun well that was good
this is such a rascal in this movie
[Music]
still smoking
oh the snow globe
[Music]
I love how they're doing these
yeah Johnny Beauty was about to flip and
Mickey Chen could testify that Falconi
ordered dense murder but why kill his
own bodyguard may I ask why you're
keeping the fifth suspect off the board
for the twist I'm blacked it out myself
obsessed with taking down Falcone he was
turned down for a gun license last year
when the psyche vow showed some wild
aberrations here it is or is it someone
else entirely I thought this would be
about sweeping criminals off the street
I never thought the Batman was going to
have to be a detective
[Music]
I really overestimated this
Batman will be what the world needs him
to be or what the world deserves the
same I believe should be said of Bruce
Wayne has a great shot yeah you're
putting on yeah I would like to thank
our corporate sponsors cord on reversal
soda polar and for the 10th year run
Gotham Broadcasting Company uh great
name drops Court boom I have it thank
you to steal that broach
one more thing we believe in family we
believe in Gotham City the sun I never
had oh no Mr Bruce Wayne oh Christ
no no no no oh dude he's freaking right
there
I mean of course but but wow great setup
of that speech dead pilot check Brown
crew check
it's time to ring in the New Year
passing your seat belts as I have no
idea how
hey yep I would expect no less I feel
like I feel like whatever this is
whatever we've tried to be to one
another is unraveling we've never spoken
of it but the truth is that you and I
are two different people one of us has
herpes now we both
I don't think we're ever going to be
able to put it all together come on the
bat in the cat I guess we're just not
cut out come on whatever this is
oh
did she know how many levels is this
conversation taking place when did you
do it
you took my watch I'm curious take it
from me Bruce around here
curiosity can get you killed oh and you
would know
[Music]
spray
to fly by didn't load it well
pretty yes the green Baron get out of
there everyone yeah you've got a chance
like so just assume that he's not gonna
do anything
oh [__]
what are you trying to prove with this
stunt Joker true stunt Joker no wait
that one's right
you think I'm holiday I didn't know you
cared
oh yep yep yep the boutonniere if I were
him why would I be trying to kill him
he's the competition I won't be number
two
[Music]
oh wow
it took me a second well I guess
everyone in Gotham Square half the
cities down there which means holiday
either is or isn't and if I fail well at
least I've killed a lot of innocent
people yep
Silver Lining no don't kill me not
before I find out who holiday is
why do you care I'm just like you we
both love a good puzzle we're both the
world's greatest detective
uh yeah to do it
[Music]
gotta contaminate all the fish in Gotham
yes
it's like please don't crash into a boat
I'm an Oxford graduate who's learned
more about business than my father could
ever hope to understand you don't get a
seat at the table because I'm weak I
fell in love how is that weak cause
Love's for Susie's yeah what happened to
her I let him scare her away from me why
do I feel like I can talk to you
I
I just
no yes let's do this oh no no I'm sorry
oh
get away from her you [__]
Bruce wait oh dude no Wayne no what
Wayne is is this the Batman Selena
Alberto Falcone is holiday what did you
just do I don't want control of the
family I never did I would happily trade
that for a normal life to get married
and have a child with you
that was so clever
okay yeah he did get shot I was like I
had firework timing was magic
oh
where okay there you could know you're
missing so many pieces oh
oh
damn that is that's a hell of a way to
go
oh
whoa
[Music]
it's the criminal on all the
neighborhood watch signs have you seen
this man he's killed everyone
he's responsible for all crime
she thinking
for Old Lang Syne boy old acquaintances
be forget whenever they're gonna split
this as a part one part two now I'm
curious hell of a way to go that isn't
how we went he was shot by holiday
before going overboard Alberta wasn't
holiday it was Occam's razor Jim the
simplest solution this is your fault
[Music]
Alberto Falcone wasn't holiday then who
is that's not important right now and
who's next we got till Valentine's Day
yes
oh
dang
so wait a minute then
is she would she have recorded the
second movie by then I don't know
wow damn
and two like this this very much feels
like a chapter break like you have just
a very sort of graceful yeah you know
coming to a I was just thinking like
where is it gonna are they gonna
escalate into the next holiday and like
I remember the comic always had that
feeling between books
uh David does small stream was uh
calendar man
that's the voice yeah of course
terrified of course his sort of like
seething eeriness yeah pitchy
uncomfortable I can definitely it's
incredible because he's like one of the
nice people in the world that he's just
so good at being terrifying well I feel
like that's yeah that's like a common
sense yeah it's like people who who play
the most sort of like uh either you know
maniacal or or just Eerie off just more
often yeah the like sweetest most
empathetic people but I guess you have
to be to to put yourself in the darkness
the less than glamorous shoes perhaps
you know man that was good yeah I really
like that a lot like I love the mood and
I love the pace like we you know after
watching so many of these and and
contrasting and comparing the DC AMU
stuff we've seen to the you know brief
excursions outside the dcamu I feel like
this still uniquely you know has its own
very patient tone and Pace that I
appreciate this and the Frank Miller
two-parter I'm really really value with
because this felt a lot like long
Halloween without trying a lot like I
said about the ring Miller one it's
adapting without trying so directly to
become it but even the Frank Miller one
like the things we loved the pauses the
taking the shot like those things they
did and that I love that this just felt
like the the world built like it didn't
try to be Tim sales art because again I
don't know if it would have translated
but instead like there was a shot of
Batman where it's like him hunt shoulder
and he's looking sideways and they
grabbed like the lighting of his cape
that looked just like Tim sale in little
moments like that for me really
beautifully grabbed the world and
obviously the writing's very Jeff Loeb
um but man that was incredible 2021
yeah this is new well and and yeah like
there's little flourishes like the Joker
uh like his design his his like fangly
Teeth oh oh
[Music]
man amen color mine if there's anything
you know what I want you to do but time
and time again you refuse me when are we
going for golf the Wayne Foundation
isn't a money laundering outfit for the
mom of course I don't believe you've met
my associate Charmed
damn it
no
cool post credit very cool
yeah like we'll go back to the uh the
cast list because like this this was
stacked uh yeah Not only was the cast
incredible but like
I really do appreciate the pacing I
really appreciate how much it loved the
source material but it's also like
such a good movie like I feel like this
is just like if you don't even like
Comics there's a lot going on here
oh yeah 100 and I mean yeah it's got so
much again cinematic flourish and it's
got these like new Irish elements like
yeah it very much feels like what I
remember about the art and the mood of
that book and and it's pretty long like
it's a thick book and yeah and you
really do feel like the
feel like it really puts you in even
though you're hopping from holiday to
Holiday you still feel like you're sort
of living in the space between it still
feels like a long year you know right as
this goes and and I feel like they've
managed to while still you know keeping
it you know in an hour and 25 minute
package or whatever still like
clipping along nicely enough but also
yeah with that same sense of breath
between everything dread like one of the
favorite things about the book is that
you're like you said a long year it does
feel like they're being uh beaten down
by the time like the time is another
villain of this because they like
there's a they know a holiday is coming
they know they failed here they know
another holiday is coming like it's the
lack of control in in this story that
they have that like doesn't work if you
rush it yeah because you don't feel the
dread of another holiday you don't feel
the dread of failure you don't feel like
grind yeah and I really think they
captured that here especially with like
this is only Halloween to New Year's
yeah I know right we still got like a
whole big old leg of the journey to go
yeah and and like you know the each time
you know they give at least a little bit
of service to the idea of what
everyone's doing for the holiday like
you know I like this story what I
remember about the story partly because
like yeah I think it's a really
wonderful Motif it's a great serial
killer motif so just a great aesthetic
Motif so you constantly have Gotham
under these different coats of decorum
and yeah
yeah yeah and so uh I don't know yeah
it's really kind of just yeah kind of
capturing and highlighting and
accentuating the unique sort of fun of
this particular story and I I think I've
read this about five years ago not quite
as long as Dark Knight but uh it's just
like a long time since I've read this
yeah it's just it's one of the classics
like this is a book I recommend to
everybody always like oh yeah also I was
completely wrong that wasn't Mark Hamill
that was Troy Baker dude I was I was
wondering that during the reaction
because the times we've heard Troy Baker
do Joker it is the one that is like he's
so close to Mark Hamilton is almost in
like I want to go now and figure out
what the yeah I know but that's the
thing is like now I want to figure out
what's the specific earmark where you
can tell when it's which one versus uh
uh yeah Mark Hamill because I feel like
whenever they they have Troy Baker do
Joker it seems like the point that
they're going for is to emulate Mark
Hamill yeah because it's so spotless
like it's so that that it doesn't seem
like it's trying to be anything other
than that yeah so yeah so I wonder I I'd
like the Tells it seem like they would
have to be kind of subtle because I feel
like he mainly worked with Kevin Conroy
so I was surprised that you know this
was a Jensen Ackles Batman I said mainly
I'm sure there's examples but like I was
like is this the last time he played
Joker because this is so recent but yeah
Troy Baker crushed it I [__] love
that performance that was so Sensational
yeah no 100 and like I love the the role
The Joker plays in this might be my
favorite Joker it could be yeah yeah
like that you asking the Phantasm like
those are my favorite like portrayals
and animation like these were solid like
the jokes were great the Mania was great
the delivery was great I also loved
Billy Burke as Commissioner Gordon yeah
good old uh Papa Twilight oh my God is
that who that is I'm 90 sure it's not
Billy Burke right isn't that like
that's who I think it is
God yes he is oh good call yeah that's
such a Billy Burke guy that's so good
he's great he's killing it Josh Jamel is
uh Harvey Dent there yeah did not hear
that one did not did not place it and
that's good because because his design
his character design reminds me so much
of Archer and when he speaks uh he you
know doesn't so like that's good it
helps to kind of separate from that uh
but yeah I think he's doing a great job
and Naya Rivera like rest in peace but I
I like her like I'm sad now the prospect
of more Catwoman portrayals from her
won't you know be on the table because
uh because I really like their back and
forth and I I love that interlude of
them chasing each other on the rooftops
and how yeah it's so flirty it's so
flirty but it's also like it's very
again atmospheric and they're not
talking a lot it's sort of just a visual
moment it's almost a silent moment that
is prolonged you know for the course of
like an entire scene and uh yeah I like
that I think is a great great aspect of
I you know a beloved novel like this
deserves or or uh The Dark Knight
Returns like things like that you know
you deserve a two-parter but it's also
you know you see why uh that's such a
good idea when you have or I don't know
you just see how much that benefits it
when you get moments like that that are
allowed to breathe that way I really
love the sound design uh in every
sequence that sequence is one of the
first times I noticed it especially but
like the use of the rain the use of like
certain
um no yeah there's just so many sound
moments in this because it's so calm and
ponderous and and that's the book the
book is very pensive and there's a lot
of frames that are just art and that's
that's kind of what we were saying
earlier with the uh the Tim sale art
maybe not just directly going to
animation because so many frames are
just like oomph still and silence and
they managed to capture that without
replicating the art yeah yeah and still
while having a striking artistic palette
I mean so many great beautiful just
Gotham Skyline shots and the way they
have this sky and the moon and all these
different things and I don't know yeah
this is really really it's a modern
production certainly and there are
elements of the animation that feel very
modern however they do have some of
those flourishes that feel like yeah
here's a big watercolor backdrop or
something giant yacht shot yeah the
background watercolor Sky you know is
always a great impact moment in this Jen
snackles Crush too I'm uh even more
excited about uh the prospect of him
playing live action one I would love
like you know we've heard him now as red
hood and we've heard now is Bruce Wayne
we'll see him again in the next
installment but uh yeah I'm loving his
portrayal so far I mean he's the right
age I play him in real life that's true
I'm just saying and I know James Gunn
like I mean the the David Corn sweat and
Rachel Bosnian casting is very much like
Twitter being like these people so uh do
your job again Twitter and uh let's get
some Jensen Ackles Batman absolutely and
it was it was Jack Quaid as Alberto it
was for him
older like my brain was like uh Jack was
young like I I like kept seeing the
wrinkles on a blurred to the face and I
was like is it him yeah that and that
was like a great performance by Jack
quick because it didn't sound young it
sounded like that like there was a lot
of little extra like edges to words and
stuff it was good work yeah and yeah he
sounds very weathered by just life what
the character has had to go through what
he sums up there uh towards the towards
the end yeah before he's murdered and I
love this yeah I mean it's it's it's of
this movie it's also of the the book but
yeah the way you have so many of
Gotham's different Rogues being like I
want to find out who this holiday is too
you know what's going on it could easily
be me but it's not me like I could have
taken my job yeah yeah yeah and having
like to go and consult and that's like a
well-worn Batman thing too is like going
to Arkham and Gathering it yeah talk to
someone from prison yeah but like I love
just the way that this particular Story
presents that and yeah you're jumping
around to all these people who would
like love to take credit but won't yeah
and I love how often like you've seen
this story adapted in different ways uh
I recently did a what to read if you
like this video and for the Batman I
recommended long Halloween because
there's a lot of slow ponderous it's
very Jeff Lowe Tim's sale there's
holidays in it like that movie is very
much that but then also The Dark Knight
the other most iconic Batman movie I
would argue uh sorry Michael Keaton as
well but like the most recent other of
the big iconic uh obviously the a lot of
the stories is like the three of them
Harvey and Gordon and Batman the giant
stack of money there's Falcone like
there's a lot but I would say the dark
tonight and the Batman are so different
totally they're connecting to this right
I mean yeah there's so much Rich story
in the long Halloween that you can adapt
The Dark Knight and you can adapt the
Batman you can have a Nolan action movie
Heist uh the Heat and you can also have
not the heat but heat and you can also
have the Batman which is you know your
your David Fincher your seven you're and
that's how strong and Rich the story is
yeah well that's what two is is so
lovely I think about comics in
particular is that you whereas like with
a novel or a book or something that is
it's one kind of thing it's like yes
this is one particular story and this is
the direct adaptation of that but yeah
you can look at multiple other
adaptations and go oh this piece of work
the long Halloween especially keeps
popping up in these aspects and details
and yeah the way you can make things
that feel so different while clearly
also drawing direct inspiration from the
same Touchstone and we've still never
had a beautiful this movie we've still
never had a long Halloween and we've had
the two biggest adaptations of recent
history not do this but do this because
it is so rich yeah so yeah I love this
as my top third uh it's gonna be really
hard when we rank all of them because uh
I think I think everything is in the top
there everything's well there's a couple
that are there's a couple it's basically
low downers top third and then a couple
yes it's gonna be a real issue yeah
that's not how math works but uh we're
gonna be ranking those or by the time
you've seen this we may have already
that is on the books we got some stuff
cooking but that when we rank our first
video just going to be the DC AMU this
will not be included we are going to do
this all when we've seen them all which
could be a couple years but uh we'll see
you very soon for that DC AMU we got a
patreon I want to get some love Tunes
give some love to a patron right who do
we got this very video
Mikhail Lyndon McHale listen up this is
a very elegant Gotham story all right
and I can just imagine you you know
sitting around the Falcone you know
table there breaking bread with
everybody made Man part of the family
but conflicted it's the holidays you got
a family of your own to think about how
did you fall into this life can you take
credit for the dastardly Deeds of foot
nay but you could do something to stop
them Mikhail because you're an
upstanding citizen of the Gotham that is
patreon all right so uh Hey keep it real
and uh stay elegant out there but maybe
put your unique and innate skills to a
more benevolent purpose you know as
we've left this movie off it's Christmas
it's New Year it's time to turn over New
Leaf Mikhail so while you would make I
think a perfect mobster I also think
that you're moral compass is greater
than a few dirty dollars if you know
what I mean family oh like the fast
family not the mob family use your
elegant crime tactics to save people
Boogie Michaela Linden great name I like
that name yeah it's a great name yeah
there's so many great comic book
characters
both the first and last name separate
and together excellent work excellent
there's a little accent a little like
Santa goo over the e in there does that
mean is it Linden
kale Linden
sort of like someone you go to for like
advice advice or like a wise some yeah
some like real yeah it's either like
Sage advice or some kind of like ancient
knowledge that is hitherto lost to man
except for by Michael Linden yeah we
appreciate you
thank you all right that's gonna do what
you lovelies we are gonna wrap on Audi
here we'll be back for the long
Halloween part yeah most likely next
week and that is very exciting stuff
because this first one was excellent
again do not envy uh us ranking them all
but they're it's coming it's it's coming
one day uh please let us know in the
comments what you want us to watch after
the long Halloween part yeah and uh
please don't yell at me for calling him
Mark Hamill it sounded a lot like him I
do apologize to everyone
retroactively I mean the people have
already written it they've already been
yelling it's already in all caps and I'm
sorry now I hope you get to this part of
the video and go man I shouldn't have
yelled in all caps I could have just
said like no call you fool it's Troy
Baker and I still would feel bad about
it but here we are here we are all right
you love you remember check out the bat
first shirt remember Comic-Con Saturday
early afternoon and remember
call your family tell them you love them
whether they're a mob family or a fast
family they're worth your love we'll
talk to you soon happy Halloween
let's see